we've said so many times on this program
over the years you know Republican
senator Susan Maine's a Susan Collins
from Maine she's got to be careful
because those Maine voters they aren't
that conservative they might hold her
accountable they might vote her out when
she's up for re-election and every
re-election since she was first elected
to the Senate in 1996 ends the same way
which is with Susan Collins getting
herself re-elected it happened in 2002
it happened in 2008 it happened in 2014
and she ends up winning with anywhere
from 58 percent of the vote in 2002 all
the way up to almost 69 percent of the
vote in 2014 and we've said it again
this year we've said you know maybe
Susan Collins supporting Trump Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh after
saying she was concerned maybe that's
going to come back to haunt her or maybe
her decision to vote for Trump not
guilty in his impeachment trial maybe
that's going to hurt her remember Susan
Collins said that Donald Trump learned
his lesson from impeachment Trump was
then asked hey Susan Collins said you
learned your lesson what lesson did you
learn Trump said he learned that
Democrats are terrible people that
listen this is Trump himself saying this
is what he learned from that lesson
Susan Collins claims exists Lisa
Murkowski mom Lisa Murkowski earlier
said that you shouldn't got involved
with the Roger stone case she said it's
just bad some Republicans have said they
hoped you would learn a lesson from
impeachment what lesson did you learn
from impeachment that the Democrats are
crooked they've got a lot of crooked
things going that they're vicious that
they shouldn't have brought impeachment
and by call numbers are ten points
higher because of fake news like NBC
which reports the news very inaccurately
probably more inaccurately than CNN if
that's possible wow he really learned
his lesson right so maybe if Susan
Collins is just going to be reelected
again but we actually have a little bit
of good news we have a new poll from
Colby College and the poll says that as
of right now 43% of Maine voters would
support for Sarah Gideon who is the
Democratic challenger to Susan Collins
for
two percent would vote for Susan Collins
now normal caveats 43 242 this is within
the margin of error could be plus or
plus or minus three in either direction
forty three to forty two if you add that
up that's eighty five that leaves
fifteen percent of the vote to be
determined that's a lot that often will
consolidate around the incumbent as we
get closer to the election it's still
early but Susan Collins rarely even has
a serious challenger so this is actually
a really big deal
even if Susan Collins gets 80 percent of
that 15 percent undecided this still
would be her smallest margin of victory
in any of her reelection campaign so
anything we can chip away at is bad news
for Susan Collins Susan Collins had the
chance to be a Republican who still
mostly makes bad decisions but who could
have done the right thing on Brett
Kavanaugh she could have done the right
thing on Trump's impeachment she didn't
and she said I was disappointed I was
concerned but then she just falls in
line with Republican Party orthodoxy we
now have the opportunity to hold her
accountable so one very good race to get
involved in if you're in Maine you can
get involved in person eventually my
guess is there will be phone banking
opportunities here as well if you live
elsewhere in the United States Sarah
Gideon's campaign against Susan Collins
Democrats have already spent a bunch of
money to try to get this seat back from
Republicans Collins popularity is down
she has some of the highest disapproval
of any sitting u.s. senator according to
recent morning consult polls so we've
got to help Sarah Gideon make progress
if she doesn't like if this stays a
one-point margin up to election day even
if it's one point margin in favor of
Sarah Gideon Susan Collins probably wins
because of name recognition having been
a senator there since 1996 it's an
uphill battle incumbency is a powerful
drug so to speak but this is I would
argue the best opportunity to remove
Susan Collins since she was first
elected in 1996 24 years ago let's do it
one of the races we'll keep our eye on
and continue spotlighting
we get closer to the November election
as many of you know I am super careful
about where we publish and distribute
david pakman show content it's a really
important decision that we make where do
we want our content to be we don't want
to spread ourselves too thin but we want
to make sure that we're taking advantage
of good platforms where our content
could do well and over the last couple
of months I've been testing publishing
our content to a platform called library
that's lbr why I've mentioned it once or
twice before and we are absolutely
loving it it's a fantastic platform
where our revenue as publishers does not
depend on some algorithm deciding
whether an ad should run before a video
or not in fact it's actually an ad free
platform where our revenue is determined
by the number of people that watch our
videos and also by the tips that are
left for us in credits that are in
platform credits it's their own sort of
currency so to speak by viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified signup we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit will get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about how it's going there's also a
contest that they're running whoever can
refer the most new users gets a huge
reward which would be a big big boost to
us so check it out link down in the
video description sign up let me know
what you think